amlaykum.
It's good to be back here in Canada. I
was just here two weeks ago. um saw some
familiar faces when I was coming in and
I want to jump straight into the topic
at hand because it's a very important
topic and one which strikes at the heart
of I would say new orientalist discourse
which in the west many people have been
trying to promulgate and it's the idea
here that
first of all is a presupposition
that Muslims or religious people in
general have faith which is true. We do
have faith. The Quran says
the ones who believe in the unseen. So
we do have faith in the unseen for
example.
But something which is not emphasized
enough in my opinion but which is very
much known in philosophical traditions
is that everyone has faith. Absolutely
everyone has faith. I mean, you just
need to pick up a basic book on
philosophy like the problems of
philosophy by Bertrand Russell who was
an atheist and one of the biggest um you
know people who criticize religious
movements
to realize this point that faith is
something which can either be true or
false. It doesn't mean that just because
you have faith that the idea of having
faith is tantamount to for example
having false faith which is which is
almost a narrative that we're exposed to
nowadays
especially as I say with the new new
orientalist liberal kind of new atheist
mix that we're exposed to
every every day almost. The reality is
everyone has faith in something. Even
things which are quite solid or at least
we perceive them to be quite solid
are actually based on axioms and theorem
like for example mathematics.
I mean we have a lot of faith in
mathematics. Now one could argue well
mathematics is something which can be
demonstrated. But the reality is this is
that mathematics has axioms and theorems
and that's well known. Axioms by
definition are things which cannot be
proven. That's how you define an axiom.
A theorem can be based on an axiom and
an axiom is something which is unproven.
Therefore, in order for us to do
mathematics,
we need to have some faith in axioms or
mathematical axioms. Now, that situation
is amplified and exacerbated with the
scientific method. You have to have
faith in science, especially
non-observable science and especially
what I would call historical science.
Atheists make it seem as if
for example the theory of evolution
is something which is undisputed
and something which has to be believed
in by anyone who is intelligent. Now I
would say fine you have evidences you
have DNA you have RNA you have fossil
records
but you also have to do some kind of
inference and that is something which
requires faith and there's no doubt
about that. There's zero doubt about
that. What story are you creating from
the fossils that you have?
And is that story the only story that
can be created from the fossils that you
have?
For example,
and this is where we need to start
owning the conversation because nowadays
we're always put in the back foot. You
Muslims base your life on faith. And by
the way, the same thing is being said
about Christians. And we atheists for
example base our life on the evidence.
No, no, no. This is a caricaturured
understanding and a false understanding,
a philosophically facious understanding
of the reality of the placement of faith
in the grand scheme of things. It's not
the case that Muslims and Christians and
Jews are the only ones who have faith.
In fact, all of us have faith.
Now the real question is what do we base
or what do we anchor our faith on that
is the question you see now what I'm not
advocating obviously is that we should
do away with mathematics and do away
with science we believe in mathematics
we believe in science we believe in
rationality we believe in logic we take
those leaps of faith every day but it
doesn't stop us from realizing that
there is a probabilistic reason for
doing that most people act in a
which shows certainty even on things
which on philosophical grounds could be
criticized or scrutinized.
And the reason why is because simply
the the weight of evidence when
presented
can be accepted can be accepted. So
the point is on a phil philosophical
level everyone has faith. This is the
kind of conclusion of the first part of
this talk. Everyone has some kind of
faith somewhere.
Now the question is now this is the
question we need to assess for ourselves
and also get the wider society to kind
of assess as well is what kind of faith
is acceptable faith and what kind of
faith is unacceptable faith.
Now the Quran answers our question and
it does so in a beautiful way and
actually it does so in more than one
way. So I'm going to recite some verses
from the Quran translate those verses
and explain what I what why these verses
are relevant to this discussion.
So Allah subhana wa tala he says in the
end of chapter 23 in verses 115 onwards
he says
Let's take this part
and think about
Allah says
do we think or does human beings think
or have they thought that they were
created
purposeless and that they will not come
to us and and return to us
glory be to Allah the melik who is the
king who is the truth
there is no god worthy of worship except
for him.
The one who is the Lord of the generous
throne.
Allah says then and who is it?
Is someone trying to correct me? I might
be wrong here. The point is Allah
subhana wa ta'ala says
this is very important and this is very
powerful because this goes to the
question of proof. Okay. And by the way
this shows you that Islam yes it's a
religion of faith but it's also a
religion of proof. Just like mathematics
in many ways
is a field of knowledge which is
concerned with truth. At the same time,
you do have to have faithful maths.
Listen to this. He says,
"And whoever calls with Allah another
god
that he has no proof for." This is very
important.
So his or his reckoning will be with his
lord.
that certainly the the disbelievers in
regards to this will not be successful.
Now this is a very hard-hitting and
powerful ayah and I want to explain why
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he says and
the key the shah here or the key point
to underline is whoever worships besides
Allah a god where there's no proof for
the point is this is that proof is
required in order for us to come to
faith
and proof is require ired for other
people to call us to their respective
faith. And that's why the Quran says,
"Bring your evidence if you are
truthful." Truth and evidence is at the
heart of Islamic inquiry.
And that's why in the same surah, Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, he gives a logical
argument for why God is one. This is
very powerful. And wall, I've done a lot
of research on this matter. This is the
best argument for why God is one. Allah
subhana wa ta says,
So,
you
Allah says Allah has not taken
a son and he hasn't taken another god
besides him as a god. Why?
Each of if that was the case if there
was more than one ultimate creator each
of those creators would have taken that
which he created. In other words, if you
have if the definition of God is that
he's the ultimate creator and there was
more than one such ultimate creator,
then there would be what you would call
tenezar or there would be a conflict in
regards to the to the things that are in
creation. Who owns the dominion would be
the question and the answer would not
have one clear answer. There'd be oh
many different entities do. Well, in
that case there is no one true
uh or all creator. There's no one
ultimate creator. But the definition of
God has to be that there is an ultimate
creator. But you can't have two ultimate
creators. Cuz if you have two ultimate
creators,
then each of those ultimate creators
would have tried to outstrip one another
for power. You can't have more than one
ultimate creator and you can't have more
than one ultimate power because by
definition that would contradict the
fact that you have one all powerful, one
all able and one all willful creator.
Let me give you an example.
For example,
let's use an easy example. Someone
driving a car, right? If you had two
steering wheels and both drivers had
different wheels,
the the the car would not be going in
one specific direction. It would be it
would be kind of stagnant from that
perspective. The car could not drive
properly. And in the same way, if there
was two steerers of the dominion or
organizers of the dominion from a
teological perspective, then we would
not have organization.
And that's why the Quran says the the
the heavens and earth would have been
destroyed. Therefore, we can prove we
can prove not only that God exists
through logical argumentation, but we
can prove that he's one.
The Quran says,
"Were they created from nothing or were
they the creators of themselves?"
Giving a logical argument. You couldn't
have been here and not here at the same
time.
As Hamza Zors says,
Hamza Zorsus, the CEO of Ayor says it's
like a mother giving birth to herself.
How can a mother give birth to herself?
It's like, you know, how how can you how
could the universe create itself? That's
a nonoption. What's the other option?
That the universe came from nothing.
That's a nonoption because it's
illogical. It's not acceptable.
Therefore, there must have been some
creator. So, we can prove God exists. We
can prove that God is one. Our faith is
based on proof. An atheist can't do
anything. All the atheists can say, and
this is called negative atheism, is just
say, "Look, I'm not satisfied with the
evidences."
Why not? Well, because it requires a le
a leap of faith. Well, so does
mathematics and so does science and so
does all these all these other things,
right? So why have you accepted those
leaps of faith and not this one? Both of
them are based on some kind of deduction
right and inference at the end of the
day when you're operating on a daily
basis you're basing your life on
inference making it's called inference
to the best explanation. So you're
coming home. If I put a dog, if I put
food, if you have a dog at home and I
put, you know,
food in the dog bowl
and I come back and and the dog bowl is
empty, the inference to the best
explanation for me will be the dog ate
the food,
right? Not my wife ate the food or my
dad ate the food, you know? And this is
a basic thing, but I could be an ultra
skeptic on this point and say, "Hold on
now. Is it conceivable that my mom ate
the food? Yes, it could be because you
know she could or could it be that? But
the thing is we make those inferences on
a daily basis. Now those inferences are
not ironclad inferences.
I mean they're subject to criticism. And
if we wanted to be hyper skeptical about
them, we could be. The point is this is
that number one yes we do have faith and
we admit that we have faith and a
sophisticated philosopher atheist will
have to admit that he has faith as well
or the lack thereof with God but faith
in other things his existence
which you can't prove demonstratively by
the way you can't prove your own
existence it's impossible because it's
first person you can't really prove it
it's very difficult to prove the best
we've got in in philosophy is I think
therefore I am which is the kaja which
has actually attacked by nature. That's
a different thing by the way. But the
point is even that can be attacked. Your
own existence can be attacked with you
have faith in your own existence because
you experience your own existence.
And so from that perspective, anything
can be doubted but not everything should
be. And this is the key principle here.
The key principle is that anything can
be doubted but that not everything
should be doubted. And if you employed a
hypers skeptical approach to all of
these other things that you do in life
which I can definitely from a
philosophical perspective cast aspersion
on
then in that case there's not much to be
said about religion that's different
from those things that you do on a daily
basis
because when you say is Islam or
Christianity whatever it may be
Christianity has been disproven by that
verse by the way because we said
Christianity but trinitarianism
is problematic because they do actually
postulate that you have three all
powerfuls which is impossible and one at
the same time. But having said that if
you
say and this is the discourse we're
hearing you require a leap of faith in
order to be a believer
and therefore it's not as um it's not as
appropriate. It's not as
it's not as scientific or whatever it
may be. It's not as rational for for me
to be a religious person as it is for
example to be a secularist or an atheist
or a liberal
right so if that is if that is what is
being said then in that case one is
being disingenuous with themselves
I'm okay good this yes yes I shouldn't
say good but but you know the point is
that so now the now we talked about
number one the problems with talking
about faith and doubt as if it's an
exclusive enterprise of religion. Then
we talked about how actually faith and
faith and certainty or faith and proof
are not um are not dualisms or
dichotoous. In other words, they're not
two separate things which cannot be
reconciled. They can be
contradistinctary. They don't have to
necessarily be contradictory. They're
not contradictions in terms. Now the
third thing is the all important
questions which relate to existence and
I'm going to finish with this because I
know the the time is running short and
this is very important. Now the all
important questions which relate to
existence
now the question is is there a purpose
of life and this is the one of the most
powerful questions
that you can ask. It is the most I
believe it's the most powerful question
that you can ask. Actually, I'm going to
be doing a talk on this question, the
purpose of life. So, I'm not going to
give too much away here. But the point
is this. The point is when we ask this
fundamental ultimate question, we're not
asking, "Have you got a purpose of
life?" These are two different
questions. If you say, "Have you got a
purpose of life?" That appeals to a
subjective purpose, which means it can
be subject to individualization,
personalization. So, in other words, me,
I have my purpose and you, you have your
purpose. That's why if you go to the
streets of Toronto, which I have done
now many times, and actually ask people
what the purpose of life is, you you're
likely to find that you have a varied
response. So, for example, someone will
say to you, the purpose of life for me
is to be uh to to be in love and to give
love or something like or to make money
or to be happy or to spread happiness or
to spread peace, whatever it may be. And
these are all what you would refer to as
positive or think at least purposes of
life. But you can envisage negative ones
as well. You can think of someone saying
or negative ones
being a serial killer, being a pedophile
or all of that is now under the
overarching
uh point of subjective purpose. Everyone
has an individualized or personalized
purpose of life. The question is not
have you got a purpose of life.
Therefore the question is is there a
purpose of life? Is there one fixed
purpose?
Is there one fixed purpose or not? Now,
an atheist can't actually answer that
question meaningfully at all. For
example, because an atheist has no fixed
purpose that they can substantiate
through any mechanism. We as Muslims
have a fixed purpose and the Quran is
very powerful in this regard. Allah
subhana t for example he says in the
Quran he says
Fore
speech.
Allah subhana t says does the human
being think that he has been left
aimless
because think about this Allah is very
very very convincing and is the most
convincing if you just think about the
ayat of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and
especially in reference to and the
Quranic arguments I can tell you this
from experience and reading tons of
books from the hellistic period up until
the enlightenment period
There is no argument that can be found
relating to God's existence and the
purpose of life which can supersede the
Quranic argument. Just look at it with a
critical eye or with an open mind.
You'll find that it's very powerful.
Allah says
does the human being think that he can
be left aimless?
Was he not a sperm drop emitted?
Then he became a clot and then he
created from that i.e the human being
and he proportioned that. Now here Allah
is making reference to the tieios
meaning to that which Allah did through
nature for the use of let's say for
instance humankind. The idea that there
was some kind of guided process through
nature.
And I've been thinking about these
verses for a very long time. Allah
equates the guided process that he
facilitates through nature with the
purpose of human life. So in other
words, the cosmos has been guided
through precision, through
proportionality
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala precisely
chose
if you like the frequency of the
universe, how everything should be
operating. And in a nutshell, without
going too much details of finetuning or
whatever, Allah basically organized
he organized the universe and he
organized it in such a way as now we can
say these are the laws of for instance
physics and just in the same way as that
we have laws of nature though we can
call them laws of physics if you want as
well which are a series of patterns that
we observe of the cosmological
environment. In that same way that
everything is submitting to the laws,
the purpose of human life does not
differ from that perspective, from that
Quranic perspective, from the purpose of
every other thing in creation.
It doesn't differ. So in other words,
what is the purpose of life for human
beings is the same purpose of life for
everything other than human.
Everything in the universe,
everything is submissive to the will
or everything is submissive to the laws,
right?
And so, and that's why Allah subhana wa
ta'ala he says
Allah says, "If the heavens and the
earth had been following their desires,
the the whole heavens and earth would
have been destroyed." That we sent them
with the truth.
Someone can correct me. Yeah. Get the
verse out. Come on. Where's the father
in Toronto? Where is it?
Allah subhanaa thank you very much for
that. Yes I challenge the the he came 3
minutes. The point is this is that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
yes he is saying that if
this is very powerful had the universe
and its organization been subject to a
chaotic order like the desires of man
then there would be no organization of
the universe in the same way
now the universe has to follow a certain
order but now the human being has to
follow the certain that same order as
well. The only difference between human
beings and jin on one hand and the rest
of creation is that we're given a
choice. But the same thing applies.
What's the purpose of life? The purpose
of life for us and jin is the same
purpose of life as for everything else
around us. The stars, the milky ways,
the universe and so on and so forth,
which is submissive submissiveness to
the law. And in this case, the law of
Allah, the law of Allah, the law maker,
the law maker. So from this perspective,
our purpose is not inconsistent or in
congruent with the rest of the creation
around us. Our purpose can be
inferred. Actually the question on
purpose can be inferred. It's a question
which is like this. We can ask is our
purpose any more or any less different
from the purpose of everything around
us? By the way, the atheist actually
quite frankly and interestingly, right?
The atheist materialist and the Muslim
has the same exact answer to the same
question if you think it from that
perspective because the atheist
materialist will say we are carbon
everything around us is carbon. We're
made from atoms. Everything around us is
atoms and therefore we're not any
different from everything around us.
Right? And so anything that happens to
me is a rearrangement of atoms. That's
their answer. We're saying yes, we are
the same as everything around us. In so
much as we also agree that there we are
the same everything around us, but in so
much as what? As we're both subject to
the same rules and regulations. But we
could decide to subject ourselves to
those rules and regulations or not to.
That's the main point of demarcation
between us and the or the inanimate.
The Quran says that Allah has caused
human beings has caused everything
around around us
to be submissive willingly
willingly or unwillingly.
But as for the human being, he's been
given a choice. So from every point
of from a logical and rational
perspective, we can actually prove
demonstrate
that this makes sense from every
perspective. It makes sense that God
exists because we couldn't come from
nothing and the universe and we as
individuals couldn't create ourselves.
It makes sense God is one because there
can't be more than one one all powerful
one all uh ultimate creator otherwise
there'd be conflict between such
ultimate creators and such conflict
would indicate weakness in at least one
of them
which means both of them are not the
ultimate creators or at least one of
them isn't and if one of them isn't then
the other one is and therefore there's
only one so one God the third thing is
what is the purpose of life and you have
two options there is a purpose an
objective fixed anchored purpose. There
isn't a purpose.
And we're saying there is a purpose and
it does not differ from the purpose of
everything else around us. Considering
the fact that there's a law maker,
there's a law maker and there's a law.
And the point of human existence is to
follow the law. And by extension, we're
submitting ourselves to those those laws
and to the law maker. And therefore, the
purpose of life is to submit our will to
God. However, doing that
someone could say, well, I have doubts
in X, Y, and Zed. But when you get those
foundations solidified in your mind,
then really everything else can be quite
easy because the truth is if the if the
roots are strong, usually the tree can
be quite healthy, right? You can't build
castles on thin air. And so the first
thing that if you if you find to answer
the question that you're having doubts
in the religion of Islam instead of
trying to deal with individual things
which are sometimes important we have to
go to the core to the fundamentals to
the foundations and we will find that
everything is answerable. Not only that,
but everything is logical and more so
than everything else that has been
presented of options from atheists,
polytheists, pantheists and every
otherist. And that's why we say Islam is
not only faith but it's certain faith
and there's no contradiction between the
two. It's not only faith but proved
faith and there's no contradiction
between the two. And with that